KCs challenged me to make a recipe
that's gone through Google translate 50
times at the end we'll see how well I
do step one warm yourself up first at
400 food cups with food plates I think
when I warm myself up I'm actually
warming up the oven okay back food cup
food plate open a big dut this is a
large rectangle oh large rectangle I ate
one earlier I don't think it's this puff
pastry sheets and felo dough well well
well I don't know which one it is this
one puff pastry and it says this is a
large rectangle pour the obtained Mass
over the chocolate then fold in half so
maybe it's pour the chocolate over the
mass rich and creamy frosting Nutella
I've baked Nutella before frosting not I
think I'm going to pour the Nutella all
over my puff pastry sheet then fold in
half cut 12 ft in length oh